was geht ab ihr sohn max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video was war
das für eine betonung sturm wie kannst
du mir sagen weiß ich nicht es ist
komisch
wir spielen jump world und ich hab das
noch nicht einmal angespielten voll
versagt es sind ja alles wie gesagt user
generierte sachen kann jetzt voll schwer
werden kann aber auch nicht schwer
während ich hab glück nicht allzu krasse
das ist vielleicht für dich
das ist wird schwer
gott ich glaube man darf nicht
stehenbleiben ich glaube es wäre ich
hab's krank maschine ok ja ich bin stehe
ich wo wir nein
man kriegt schon mal keinen schaden
hoffentlich ist es nicht falsch er ist
die frage in home richtig glauben kann
oder man kommt ihr nicht wo du bist
richtig du bist doch ein bisschen sauer
dass nicht betrogen reingelegt
schoppitsch nichts ich habe halt ich
glaube du bist doch wie kommt man rein
ich weiß nicht ich habe ich keine ahnung
aber ich muss ich muss mein allerbestes
nur muss man abgeben
nein auch man es aber gecheckt aber
jungs cool dass das irgendwie immer mit
so so so abschnittweise ich weiß nicht
inwiefern die der vorgaben gemacht haben
dass server chip gar nichts gar nichts
echt also die komplett frei bauen auf
sein wir bayer ärgern weil irgendwie
gerade eben bei der kleinen leute ab die
wir gespielt hat ja schon das gefühl
dass sie immer so kleine abschnitte
gehabt haben und das ist jetzt hier auf
bedeutet oder sogar ersetzen normal das
ist hier für angenehm für die dynamisch
monate geschafft leute geschafft jetzt
muss ich gas gibt
warum gleich bei sowas überstehen dann
kann man es erst recht nicht schaffen
ich bin auch schon bald so schlecht wenn
ich weiß nicht was mit dem uran zu
aufnehmen heute ist übung ist es kommt
jetzt
ich finde das voll cool weil das volle
schöne so nebenbei zeitvertreib leute
die ein auto zu quatschen irgendwie ne
also wenn mein team hat und nicht so wie
ich vollkommen überfordert ich
verletzten so schwierig tja diese
kossakowski teenager schon weil du
kannst nicht den schwung mitnehmen
ich habe auch gesagt nein ich habe voll
fest meine tastatur gedrückt wenn man
die fässer rück springt man ja ireland
müsste man höher springen bringt sich
hören und einfach lienen höher weiter
und besser ich glaube wir sind echt
schon gut für mein base ist so schwer
der letzte echte nie ist er so eine 44
blog sprung der letzten zeit meinen
weiter anhalten muss warmwasser du hast
ihn roman story gefühl ich hätte jetzt
noch mein ganzes leben noch mal nach
hinten vielleicht schaffe ich es jetzt
der perfekte mann da kommt was war das
denn ich wieder ganz anerkannte
abgesprungen
das ist nicht gut
jetzt bin ich im haus jetzt kommen wir
mal gucken wir mal vielleicht kann ich
mir du bist ja gemeinerweise angeber
oder es geht dabei spielen wir doch
so ausrasten
ich schneide versprochen ich habe
einfach so geschafft ich noch nicht
drüber nachgedacht ich habe einfach so
geschafft wo bist du runter gefallen
noch im haus oder das fast schon den
nächsten chef warnt es gibt nur noch den
dass der nächste check point ist das
ziel
vielleicht schaffe ich weiß das ist
großes problem ist im letzten sprung ist
wieder so ein sprung und du musst das
ganze haus hoch war der konnte ja und
wenn du verkaufst muss das alles neu
machen dass an dieser säule hoch geht es
ziemlich schwierig ist einfach nur
langwierig weil ja das ist ja das ja
überhaupt nichts mehr wenn er das einmal
irgendwie kannst dann müsste ja beim
setup ja ich hab's geschafft und das
wird richtig eltern ich wäre jetzt hab
ich wieder meine tasche war es einfach
schwierig macht einfach ab ok dann geht
in die nächste runde abgabe mich was ist
was reihe da kam ich bin nicht gestorben
das bedeutet für mich ich verliere gott
oh gott oh gott was das denn ich weiß
doch speedtest weiteres mal du bist
neugierig hinter mir habe ich die katze
auf bürger man wie kommen die zu hoch du
wirst dein arsch nein ich weiß nicht ich
glaube mir scheint aber noch die grünen
ja ruft sie meinte nein die sind richtig
schlechter krimi dialog das war so
knackig eigener band ich hätte weiter
dass das aber cool mit den ländern ein
alter ich bin hier drin es passiert
nichts passiert doch auch nein ich
glaube bruder geworfen wo bin ich muss
irgendwohin werden in nr
denn töten und angeblich will doch nicht
dein ernst muss jetzt hin dass nämlich
richtig bin ahmad o gott ist es so nur
dropper scheiße glaube ich denken über
einen tag geschafft nicht dein ernst ist
okay gut gut ja durch weißt du was nehme
ich halt einfach mitmachen ist einfach
durch die wand kannst du das bild auf
einmal oben luft mir hast du das recht
durch die wand bank geschafft ich bin
einfach über dem handy ist richtig so
wobei nicht ganz ist es richtig hier
wussten dass es hier echt da wo was drin
ist wirklich versprochen
also trat man musste man muss hier hin
ich habe ich einfach durch gepackt jetzt
noch immer noch die ender perlen gerade
eben hertie verlierst du nämlich nur auf
den jackpot auf den silbern aber zählt
das so ja story bridge jump and run
slade von sturm war schön aber noch ein
ja sehr gerne einfach mal noch leben
oder nicht
mieterwechsel der rekord alter was ist
da alles abzulesen ist aber richtig
schön aus das gefällt mir gut ich bin
einfach wieder zurückgeworfen worden
weil du gekommen bist ich glaube daran
gekommen bist du gekommen radar oder
nicht sagt nicht so bist du schon mal
dort wo bin ich hier unterbrechen das
kurze interview hier so viel check point
ok kurz verwirrt gewesen
hoch das ist echt so könnte ist es so
schwierig hey nein ich stand gerade
einfach auf dem 1
auf dem einen auf dem einheit auf dem
einen okay erzählt ruhig weiter erzählte
ich will konzentrieren
das orientiert nur an die scheibe werfen
und nicht bewegen
okay okay so kann dinge
das macht viel spaß leute es ist auf
jeden fall mal so eine kleine challenger
beine
ja ja irgendwie auch diese gewissheit
dass man eigentlich so gut wie immer was
neues haben kann
ja
revolutionary gibt es in der deutschen
szene so nicht wo hier noch mal wollte
ich aber lange grün gleich leben rot
gleich tot okay gut dass immer schwer
das mag ich nicht voll getroffen wie
weit bist du denn dass du schon
irgendwas von grün gleich leben rot
gleich tot hast bist du schon über die
wolken jetzt geradeaus hast du geworden
ich werde probieren das selbst fertig zu
machen würde
und da mach ich fertig und auch an
wieso war dann plötzlich der schampus
weg oben oben ist der weg ganz beim
letzten so jetzt kommt dies war der fall
stehe jetzt kommt dieses leben
teilgenommen hat ist dabei ja weil ich
gerade sein muss muss folge von
aufpassen beim springen weil das voll
ungewohnt es war so viel früher
abspringen muss ja stimmt eine total
merkwürdig welt.de darf man nicht stur
miklik noch mehr und da ist okay wir
richtig dass kreativität gut gut gut
wenn kohl den modus ich finde auch echt
cool dass uns der firma aufnehmen
wollt ihr dass auch leute dann legt mich